[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره
نفتح المتحدث باسم هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه ان تكون طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اتفقطا على تركيب كاميرات
مراقبه جديده في المنشات النوويه واكد
المسؤول الايراني ان زياده عمليات التفتيش
في منشاه فوردو بنسبه 50% وفق اعلان جروسي
هي ضمن اتفاقيات الضمانات بعد رفع نسبه
التخصيب
وكانت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اصدرت من فيينا بيانا مشتركا مع هيئه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في ختام زياره
المدير العام للوكاله رفايل روسي الى
طهران وقال البيان ان ايران مستعده
لمواصله التعاون مع الوكاله بشان ثلاثه
مواقع قالت الوكاله انها غير معلنه وعثرت
فيها على اثار لليورانيوم
في طيران نقل مراسلنا عن الرئاسه
الايرانيه قولها ان الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
ابلغ جروسي ان طهران تامل من الوكاله
التعامل بمهنيه وعدم التاثر بقوى سياسيه
تسعى لاهداف خاصه
نظم الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل تجمعا
عماليا واسعا بالعاصمه في اطار سلسله
تحركاته الاحتجاجيه الاسبوعيه واكد الامين
العام للاتحاد ان الاتحاد يرفض خطاب ترهيب
الناس وتصفيه الحسابات ولم يقبل بقمع
الحريات ولا بعوده الاستبداد حسب تعبيره
قالت جمعيه القضاه التونسيين ان تصريحات
الرئيس قيس السعيد تجاه القضاه تشكل خطوره
وتدخلا مباشرا في التحقيقات وادعت الجمعيه
الرئيسه الى الكف عن الاجراءات الانتقاميه
ضد القضى مشيره الى وجود ضغوط غير مسبوقه
يتعرض لها القضاء على اثر الاعتقالات
الاخيره
قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في ليبيا
عبد الحميد الدبيبه ان اي قاعده دستوريه
يجب ان تطرح او تطرح للاستفتاء امام الشعب
كما اكدت بيب رفضه عوده الحكم العسكري
مجددا الى البلاد
في المقابل قال رئيس مجلس النواب الليبي
التعديل الدستوري الذي اقره مجلس النواب
يلبي تطلعات الليبيين لاجراء الانتخابات
قال قائد العمليه الخاصه بالقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات بلاده في باخموت
تعمل في ظروف شديده الصعوبه واضاف خلال
زيارته الى المدينه ان قواته تبذل قصار
جهدها لوقف هجمات
بالمقابل تفقد وزير الدفاع الروسي قوات
الشرق في محور جنوب دونيتسك واكد على
اهميه ضمان تقديم الدعم الشامل لقوات هذه
الوحده وتنظيم عمل وحدات الدعم
اعلنت الصين عن زياده ميزانيه العسكريه
بنسبه
27% هذا العام وقال رئيس الوزراء الصيني
انه لابد من بناء القدرات العسكريه
والاستعداد التام للقتال مشددا على اتخاذ
خطوات حازمه لمنع استقلال تايوان
انتهى الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]